GOALTENDING LIKE PROTECT OF
HIGH STICKS IN E POINT IT COMES
VAN RIEMSDYK, OVI IN HIS WAY
GETS OUT OF IT
SLAVIN SHOT.
DELAYED PENALTY,  SCREEN IT MAY
NOT BE SHOTS
ON GOAL DURING THE POWER-PLAY
SE
ALLOWED WASHINGTON TO HANG ON
TO THE PUCK WHICH . ANDERSEN
SCREEN PENALTY COMING UP, TEMPT
THE SH
NET TIPPED.
ANDERSEN GOES BEHIND HIM AND
OUT IT TO SPACE.
ROOM, SHOT SCREEN IN SAVE. UNFO
HE RUNS OUT OF ROOM NOT ITTY.
HE KNOWS HE HAS THE OFFENSIVE .
>>John: 1-0
OVI IS OPEN, NO SHOOTING ANGLE
>>John: REDIRECTION HIS RIGHT I
CORNER LOOKING FOR HELP  THIS N
FINDS THE BACK OF THE NET
GREAT EFFORT BY THE CAPS
TURNOVER NIEDERMAYER WALKING IN
SHOT
NUMBERS MANTHA SOMETHING HAPPEN
THIRD CHANCE. AKING IT OUT TO T
OVECHKIN GOES TO GET IT-YEAR-OL
SVECHNIKOV THROWS ACROSS
REBOUND SAVE.
FOR THE HURRICANES SHOT SAVED BY
VANECEK, AND ON THE SCORE
REDIRECT. BYPASS
SHE.
MANTHA IS ONE OF THOSE GUYS